down in a sense uh so this is a huge
stage you know as we're kind of
rebuilding back to like potential
offline terms returning right uh so i'm
excited to see this one you mentioned
he's a jaguar main right or is it only
king yeah
he uses king and armor king but you know
recently he's been playing noctis so he
might pull out the noctis here and if it
doesn't work he's probably going to go
for the armor king
yeah aka of course we've seen time and
time again
but look at this
[ __ ] rob
wow
wow okay and aka with the [ __ ] take into
account yeah
you know when you're trying to win
you're trying to win uh damn all right
tomorrow let's see what you got here
with the [ __ ] rob
aka with the shane classic
you know classic a.k.a you hear you hear
aka's name you already associate him
with the shaheed so let's see how
effective this is
here in this infinite stage also so a
lot of movement gonna happen in this
game oh
he's trying to break those pokemon legs
early
he's taking his time right now breaking
his legs and we talked about ak being
persistent with whatever move he decides
to go with it right now he's breaking
the leg and there's the low parry
outside of bridge this is really good
for tomorrow but instagram standing free
weird stuff coming from tomorrow also
gotta watch a rage drive here running
three and tomorrow
gets the first round in the set
float no convert he didn't try to
convert i think he could have got him
there
yeah unfortunate
ak follows up the combo full damage
somewhere you're almost at half health
he tried to go for the slide there you
saw that
oh yeah
yo jet kick
[Music]
man unfortunate trade there for tomorrow
again trying to open him up with the
load this time but ak's also doing the
same but the timing is there for the
launcher and ak finishes him off one
round a piece
yeah that was a really good call out on
the downfall too because he has such a
big likely that tomorrow had to come in
right so he's just waiting for the time
and that down for two because he's like
you're gonna run into something
eventually it's gonna be this launcher
great
okay oh
follow up by ak forward four big trouble
gets hit by the orbital and he killed
this combo i don't think so though
what the okay rage mode [ __ ] rom
the same situation right he's got the
life lead
tomorrow canvas getting hit by get a
kick left ak off the ground
[Music]
round four that timing from ak down
three as soon as tomorrow tried to
approach but the thunder kick tomorrow
catches him again gets before combo win
bob
oh my goodness
break it oh my god akp looking really
good
the down four
tomorrow takes it to a final round
yo ak's a nut
down 4-2 for the keep out this time
oh my god
all right i've been talking a lot trash
by shaheen but ak made me want to play
him right there
break his legs
he catches him off guard tomorrow is he
done for here in this one no one more
hit is
what a jerk
that was fantastic that was fantastic uh
aka doing ak things out here uh and yeah
it was so good right because he's timing
on the orbital there after he set him
with so many lows like he's like no he's
not gonna do anything about these lows
until i bring out the orbital then he's
gonna dug for it it was just so well
played and you know when you're ak
you've done this 100 times 100 players
you know it's just another one in your
list so for everyone else you're like
he's not going to do it again he's not
going to it's going to do it again and
then you start panicking right now
now you know your mind is all over the
place you don't know which way to look
you don't know which way to block uh
it's looking kind of rough to be honest
and one of the biggest highlights for ak
is also back way back in evil japan
where he got second place remember that
right you were there evil japan ak he
fought against cbm he did five slides in
a row against him and cbm did not block
that's the type of play style aka is
bringing to the table with us right now
and he's still doing it to this day
yeah it doesn't matter what kick you
know earlier we're talking about like
the akuma option that he had before
right uh well he was just down for you
like nine times in a row he he's very
persistent with one move and
you don't as a player when you're going
against something like that you don't
expect it even though you've seen him do
it time and time again to so many
players you still don't think it's going
to happen he's like he's he can't like
why would he do it seven times in a row
that makes no sense to me
but sure enough we get a character
switch we get
armor king this time uh bringing out for
tomorrow
and of course this character
as we mentioned earlier a little bit
stronger now we've seen more and more
armor kings showing up in tournaments
uh ak though with the shaheen keeping
him on the map
oh yeah i i love that uh i love that
armor king is getting a lot of
representation here especially in the
philippines that nobody not a lot of
people use him it's uh
you know just a couple of my friends and
not much in top eight tournaments so
this is really this is refreshing to see
wow doubt the wildfire just out of range
that time
man did you start breaking those legs
oh no you remind him about the slides
you're mine
i can't believe you heard me it's the
casters first tomorrow
the nut punch we're going to carry to
the wall there it is
welcome
aka okie combo doesn't break the giant
swing he's dead oh
face first to the wall downtown tomorrow
first round
nicely done there
we go yeah playing a bit more slow this
time around
yeah it's kind of odd right okay
yo break his legs all day go back to
that it was working oh that's why it was
working
you know and that's the seed that were
planted in game one
okay again the slides not a single one
has been blocked by tomorrow but the
timing on the launcher again ak catches
him and takes it one round a piece we've
seen this movie before fight
exactly and you know that that's the
game plan right now right he wants to
get him frustrated that when he has a
life he comes running in and then the
dow 402 is there for the keep out you
know prior to that it's all the low
pokes it slides uh to really break his
defense right now you can see tomorrow
he's guessing on everything
so late hop he punished
speaking of guessing ak did guess right
there he blocked the low and now he's
one round away from sending tomorrow
to the losers bracket
dude that down 42 is from downtown
breaks the last wall here we're going
this way though
tomorrow you're showing some signs of
life here aka looking for more slide
mix-ups uh mix-ups in some way they're
playing a bit more safely this time
gotta be careful about that launcher
though the df2 good break on the shining
wizard
yeah that's a great point he really has
to stay away from this
and not get caught by a downforce when
he's trying to get some off and start
himself
raise more
ak
rate drive of course
patience there by tomorrow there they
try to use the delay to bait him into it
but no go final round game two
tomorrow not out of it yet dice ring a
multithroat could be huge
on point with punishment tomorrow there
so you know his head is still in the
game no duck on the second hit but ak
continuing the aggression that's the
first flight and that's the first slide
that he blocked this entire set tomorrow
right now working on
getting into a game three what's he
gonna do
guys waiting the wall could kill here
[Music]
oh good
got him handspring
tomorrow
on the board showing some signs of life
i love it tomorrow adjusting perfectly
well now aka
is very comfortable with the stage this
is nor this is normally his go-to stage
whenever he loses a match right the
howard estate so we might go for an
instant rematch here or
he might go for the geometric plane
which we've been seeing quite a lot in
the recent tournament we've had here
interesting you know i i really like the
army king player that's coming out of
tomorrow so far uh obviously the biggest
question mark here is you know those
seeds that were planted by ak in the
first game with the lows repeatedly you
know breaking his legs mixing up with
the slides now in game two you know
where is the defense gonna be in game
three uh and when you play this game
that ak's playing it gets a little risky
right because you know these things are
very punishable on block if you can
guess correctly so ak is really counting
on these things to pay off uh but you
know if tomorrow's defense holds up here
uh and he's blocking standing for the
majority time here it's gonna be like a
lot easier for him but that being said
that's the whole mind game right like
it's easier to stand and guard and take
all the lows but against ak you know
he's willing to do 10 lows in a row
so
it's a very interesting mind game uh
we'll see what happens but i'm very
curious and obviously we saw the one
giant swing worked out we told me we
were earlier uh it's something he tried
to go back to again ak was ready for the
breaks the second time i would love to
see you know some of those commandos the
multi-throws that arm king has come into
play
oh yeah
boys and girls
no mix-up mix-up is a real thing
you gotta be careful when you're
fighting ak because he will do the same
thing over and over again until you
eventually manage to like block one or
two of those so again we're sticking
with the howard estate stage this is a
case comfort pick
but let's see if tomorrow can close this
one out against you know the guy the
stars of the entire uh this entire
country ak
foot exactly this is the time to get
your name on the map
low parry from ak
it's been primarily all offense right
and keep on the keychart you were
talking about it yeah
get into the wall and key charge for the
mix
whip gets the wall slap in he's gonna
get the wall break also unfortunate
stuff for me oh no he didn't he misses
the second hit of the scorpion kicks
rage mode last pixel just a little short
a little desperate there with the grab
attempt
uh didn't even get the full shining
aka first round
yeah for sure here we go down four
that's only the first one tomorrow is he
gonna block those eighties looking for
more orbital heels there it is again
three oh no oh he canceled okay okay ak
ready for defensively as well
slides are coming
i don't think so oh my goodness
so marina's been conditioned to hell by
aka the slides and then goes for the big
mid ak
super good conditioning here
block the slide this time here comes
tomorrow small combo off that slide you
need to block eight slides to win that
round that's not gonna happen
the delayed hopkins ak with the showboat
takes it against tomorrow two to one
sending him to the losers bracket rip
what'd i tell you what'd i tell you man
did you tell me
i expected that to happen all along what
were you telling me um
aka he's ak he's the star of the
philippines he's moving into the
winner's final top three guaranteed
congratulations aka tomorrow though he
looked pretty good there right obviously
the conditioning came into play you're
spot on about that as well uh you know
and tomorrow unfortunately does have to
go down to that loser bracket that shark
infested loser bracket of course waiting
for the winner between rgn and sidestep
lance uh we also got t-rex down to loser
back we saw him lose to jules earlier
he's he's waiting for the winner between
coffee prince and maru uh so lots of
crazy action still to come here we're
just getting started uh but we do have a
winter spinal squared away at least
later tonight will be omega's jewels
versus pbek
oh such an exciting match to see
everybody's been seeing this you know
match up over and over again and quite
frankly they don't get tired of it
they always would love to see this kind
of matchup jules versus ak in the world
oh yeah and this isn't even granted
i mean we might get it for the grand
finals too right we'll see how we'll see
how this loser bracket plays out this is
gonna be a good one uh ak shaheen
definitely very fun to watch uh you know
some of my friends have been trying to
get me to play shaheen uh and shaheen
to me is just so boring but watching 8k
playing right now i gotta say it's a
little bit more interesting you know but
i feel